pou dou dou
th
生み出すからし今日はこれについて皆さんとお話ししたいと思います
2011年に入学した小学生のうち約65%が今
存在していない仕事につくだろう
これは2011年ニューヨークタイムズに掲載された研究者の言葉です
これすごいことだと思いませんか
私たち今の働き方があと10数年でもしかしたら変わってしまうかもしれない
アメリカのことですが近いうちに日本でも同じようなことが起こるかもしれません
このように私たちの働き方は大きく変わってきています
私はその時代を変化を肌で感じながら育ってきますか
私は1986年バブルが始まった年に生まれました
物心ついたころにはバブルは弾け耳に入ってくるニュースは大企業のリストラ
それから東山リーマンショック
お金の価値ですら一変してしまうようなそんな場面に立ち会ってきますか
だから正直昔の大人たちが言っていたようにいい会社に入って結婚して
大きな家を買えば幸せになれる
正直ピンと来ないんです
これだけ速いスピードで移り変わる地この時代に幸せに生きていくためにはきっと前と
同じ方法じゃダメなんじゃないだろうか
そう思っていた時に私の価値観を変える大きな出来事と出会いました
それが3.11です
私は関東に住んでいて直接的な被害はありませんでした
それでも食料の買占めガソリンが手に入らないコミュニケーションがとれずに治安が
悪くなったり
私たちが今まで当たり前だと思っていたシステムがいかに不安定なものだったのか
それを痛感したのです
そして私自身がこの不安定なものにどれだけ依存していたのか
これからはよは彼がどんなに変わっても自分で生きていける技術と助け合いや
コミュニティをつくっていかなきゃいけない
そう決心しました
して制裁から3年その場をつくる
素敵な場所と巡り合うことができました
それが福岡県糸島市です
山回りカバーも割海もあり自然豊かな集落です
私が住んでいるところは16世帯に応じは4つしかありません
水道もなくみんなで湧き水をシェアせながら暮らしているようなところです
ここで私たちは私たちの暮らしの基本止まる
食べ物
仕事エネルギーを自分たちで作っていこうと決めました
ん
その舞台となるのがこの糸島シェアハウスです
このなら銀の住人たちが仲良く助け合いながらからしています
我が家の特徴は一人一芸
みんなが自分の持っているスキルを活かしながら暮らしを作りそして仕事を作ってい
ます
では個性豊かなメンバーを紹介していきたいとおもいます
左か料理に着物の着付け師
それから音楽家写真家農家
酒屋そして私です
私の職業はというと
実は新米漁師をしています
私のなかなか良やっているようには見えないと思います
こんなどこにでもいる私がなぜ修行するようになったのか
それはやはり3.11の時に感じた
この世の中の仕組みについて違和感を感じたことでした
今私たちの社会はとても大きくなっていて仕事は分業化が進んでいます
もちろんそれがあったからこそ暮らしが便利になってお金を出せばお肉が買えるように
なりました
それでもそのキー違反されてしまった過程を想像できる人がどんどん少なくなって
しまっているような気がします
例えば今朝食べた朝食その向こう側に命を感じることができる人がどれだけいる
でしょうか
私はそのつながりを取り戻したいそういう思いから資料を始めました
もちろん一番最初街の姿勢をとっていたわけではなく鶏をさばくところから始めました
そしてその体型をシェアするべく鳥を占めるワークショップを企画したり
その羽でアクセサリーを作ったりもしました
それでも
動物たちが自分の毛もとにやって来るまでよ
しっかり感じなければその過程を体験したことにはならないのではないだろうか
そう思い漁をすることにしますか
この真ん中にイノシシが映っているのわかりますか
これは私の罠にかかった ncc です
両やってるんだというとアレでしょうぱでしょうって言われるんですけど私は鉄砲は
使いません
箱に閉じ込めるわけでもなく
クリームというバナーを使っています
山に入って動物の足跡多い
その通り道に穴を掘って罠をしかけます
この花は足にワイヤーが引っかかってみようこげが取れなくなるという間だなのです
なので生きている動物にとどめを刺すのが私の仕事です
鈍器のようなもので動物を気絶させ
走って近寄り
鼻先をしで抑えてこの耳から首にかけてをナイフで切ります
ここには大きな血管が通っていてここか知恵を出すことによってお肉が
獣臭くならないようになります
動物木とどめを刺すたっけ
唐物の鳴き声がもに中に響き渡ります
とどめを刺した後は私の身も心も
疲れきってしまいます
それでもそこでやめるわけにはいけません
とどめを刺した動物を内蔵を取り出さなければいけません
そうしないとお肉が傷んでしまうからです
内臓を取り出し毛皮をハゲそしてようやく食べられるお肉になるのです
家がーなめしという加工を加えてカバンや楽器などを作ります
当別の雨等を[ __ ]にしたりキャンドルにしたり
それから内臓の
堪能というところは胃腸薬にもなります
こうして一つの命を使い切る
これは私が資料で学んだことです
それでは
個性豊かな私たちシェアハウスのメンバーを紹介したことところで私たちの食べ物を
作るというところを説明していきたいとおもいます
自分たちの食べ物は自分たちでつくるをテーマにこの美しい棚田に田んぼと畑を持って
います
ここでは野菜を作っています
そして車で5分も行けば海があります
そこで若いやワカメイカなど季節によっていろんなものが撮れます
季節のものと言えばをニックのシーズンは冬です
私たちはお肉も自分たちでとってきます
我が家はお肉の自給率が100%の家なのです
なので私たちの食卓に上るお肉は豚や牛ではなく野生のイノシシやアナグマです
この中で猪食べたことあるよーという人いらっしゃいますか
あ
結構多いでしてだ穴窯はいかがでしょ
穴川ただた方が早かった
あいらっしゃいますね爪操作の多分皆さんあなたはどういう動物なのかわからないと
思います
これ雷のたぬきよりもちょっと大きな動物で肉付きがすごくいいんですがその脂が
フルーティーでとても美味しいと言われています
こういった野生の動物たちはは等に係る直前まで自由にのびのびと走り回っている動物
たちです
私は動物の解体を始めてお肉を食べるということはその動物と自分がどうかすることだ
と感じるようになりました
自分の体のあるものならやっぱりハッピーに生きてきた者と同化したいですよね
お肉の自給率100%にはもうひとつ理由があります
それは私たちが家畜は食べないゆるめでの食べ方をしているからです
はないですお肉が出るのは自分たちで撮った時か鯖江た時だけ
身の丈に合った食べ方をというのは我が家の食卓です
烏骨鶏を育てて食べるということも挑戦しました
山に狩りに行くのと自分で育てて食べることは全く違うものです
毎日餌を上げればなつきましもしかしたら私のことを親と思っていたかもしれません
そんな風に大切に育てた烏骨鶏を自分の手で締めるのはとても心が痛かったです
それでも一つの命が生まれて私の体の中に入っていく
その過程を最初から最後まで体験できたこと
これはかけがえのないことだと思います
今まで私たちが食べてきた本の人気のお肉もこうして育ってきた命だったんだと
c 息を感じました
こうして美味しいご飯と動物の命がダイレクトにつながる
それが前の食卓です
二つ目エネルギーを作る
エネルギーの自給ってなかなか難しいことだと思います
私たちはその第一歩として太陽光パネルの発電機をみんなで作りました
自然の中からエネルギーを作り出すという点では
巻も大切な燃料ですこのロケットストーブは小さな声だで
500度600度の熱が作れるという調理器具です
このロケットストーブという調理器具を使用済みの一斗缶を使ってみんなで作りました
そのあたりに落ちている小枝を燃料にして使えるのでどこでも料理が出来る優れもの
です
これは韓国式の床暖房オンドルと言います
これは薪を燃やした絹いる部屋を暖めるというと変わった仕組みなんです
まずこのように床下に石のメールを作ります
その上に石を重ねて大きい
間を埋めていきます
隣から火を炊き込んでその煙りが先ほどの迷路の中を進んでいきます
煙が石を温めゼンマイと部屋が立たないます
コーンフードルの素晴らしいところはまキウイ3本で一日中を戦いということです
残念ながら古民家の冬はとても寒くて去年は光熱費がかなりかかってしまいました
今年はこのんぼるが大活躍してくれることを楽しみにしています
そして私たちの暮らし自立した暮らしをつくるために
自分で仕事をつくることは欠かせません
私も去年7月に仕事をやね自分のスキルを少しずつ仕事にする練習を始めました
ネットがあれば仕事ができるのでこうやって庭に出て発電しながらゆるゆると仕事をし
ています
そして我が家は住人たちの個室以外にもこのように広いイベントスペースがあります
ここでライブをやったりワークショップをやったりしつけ教室をやったり
住人たちが自分が持っているスキルを活かしながらここで仕事を生み出すのです
こういうふうにたまには写真をスタジオにも平成します
定期的にマルシェも行います
ここは私たち12そして地域の人たちの仕事の場だけではなく交流の場にもなってい
ます
多いときには70人以上の人たちが我が家に遊びに来てくれて楽しい時間を過ごします
ここまで我が家の暮らしを紹介しましたが本当にこの暮らしやっていけるのと思う方が
いらっしゃるかもしれません
でもわたしたちのくらし田んぼと畑とそして頂き物のおかげで食費は月々1人当たり
5千円から6千円
光熱費食費家賃全部含めても
月に3万円合えば食べるものと口食べるもの等進むところには困りません
これってすごく大事なことだと思いませんか
東京だったら考えられない値段です
私たち違い等の技術そして特技を仕事にしていくのはとても時間はわかります
なので暮らしにかかる最低限のコストを減らすことによってリスクを減らしながら自分
のスキルを仕事にしていく訓練をしているんです
あって不安なく新しいことに挑戦すればそういうものがもっと増えたらいいとも思って
います
最後に未来のことについて話したいと思います
私たちの暮らしまだまだ仕事
食べ物エネルギーを全部受給するまでには至っていません
それでもただひたすら消費するだけの暮らしではなく自分たちで生み出していくという
ことにつよいつよいかの示唆を感じています
そして今皆独身なんですけれども
これからは皆が結婚して子どもを産んでも一緒に暮らしていく村づくりをしていきたい
と思っています
そしてずっと変わらない暮らしの技術を身に付け身につけていくこと
一番最初に話したようにこれから10数名のうちに無くなってしまう仕事もあると思い
ます
インターネットももしかしたらなくなるかもしれません
それでも私たちが生きていく上で食べる
暮らす人間の根本的な物ってずっと変わらないですよね
そういう技術を身につけていきたいとおもいます
ここまですごいマジメに語ってしまったんですけれども私は本当にこの暮らしが楽しく
て仕方ありません
彼は写真を見てもらえばわかると思うんですけど毎日が修学旅行のようでこんな歳に
なってもまだ新しい発見や驚きがたくさんあります
私はこの暮らしのワクワクドキドキにこれからの未来があるんじゃないかと思ってい
ます
生み出す暮らしは楽しい9らしい
皆さんはこれからの激動の時代どうやって生き延びていきますか
そのアイディアをシェアできたら嬉しいです
ありがとうございました
ます
i am